the Joe Rogan experience did you see
that the LA is there they have a number
now we could turn in businesses that are
flying like what what is going on why
what is this
who's doing that but this is bad
government listen there's zero effort
talking about giving people information
than how to strengthen your immune
system zero yes zero effort zero effort
talking people about lowering stress
levels through meditation and exercise
zero yes zero the importance of keeping
your body healthy
zero zero talk about this yeah zero
concentrating on the the the new data
that's coming in about vitamins and all
the different vitamin deficiencies yes
dr. Rhonda Patrick knocked it out of the
park on the podcast yesterday [ __ ] man
it's crazy these people would just like
stay home locked up snitches get
stitches basic childhood etiquette well
they were first given snitches for
people who are violating social
distancing but now they're moving on to
businesses that are non-compliant but
how are you supposed to make money how
are you supposed to make money I don't
understand this like what is the thought
but here's the crazy thing
Garcetti said we're gonna keep LA on at
least partial lockdown until there's a
cure okay it's not gonna be a cure you
[ __ ] dummy it's a virus and it's
isn't it a cold virus yes yeah sure
viruses yeah and unless you find a way
to eradicate it from the the actual gene
pool but did he actually say that yes
sure you can't say that first of all I'm
sure what he meant is like a viable
treatment that you know a vaccine but
they're saying that even a vaccine
there's never been a corona virus
vaccine mayor LA will never become never
completely reopened until we have a cure
that's his that's his quote that that
just seems I mean we don't have a cure
for the flu that poor lady who is the
health lady someone needs to give her a
stake and let her lie outside the Sun
would Jesus Christ you're the health
lady it's a little bit light like it's
pandemic light it's certainly not like
the 1918 not even close but look how
right we're reacting like it is which I
think was precautionary but but it's
still going on now they're asking people
to rat people out if you're [ __ ]
opening up your business Gestapo yeah
it's what it's always worried is are we
the frog in the boiling water we're at a
certain point you say hey everybody
self locked down and don't work and
everyone's like yeah I'm not stoked
about it but okay I'll do that for my
fellow man and then a couple of months
go by and the numbers come in and you're
seeing you know you're not seeing the
outbreak in Florida from the spring
breakers you're not seeing they they're
well they've been open now yeah I was
just there I flew to Florida last week
for the UFC yeah Saturday night I flew
in and so they're just I would do a
restaurant Prichard sat down how to
stage had a glass of wine my friend
Eddie Bravo I'm sat down eight together
like we see it and it was strange at the
restaurant because it was like us and
then this other older couple walked in
there was maybe one other couple towards
the front and a couple young people at
the bar fairly sparse all the waiters
had face masks on yeah we ate weight
dinner but now we can spear sea
theorists and me is like now they're
gonna see how far they can [ __ ] push
it I don't think that's a conspiracy
theory I think that is just like your
cult friend that was calling you a
scumbag and trying to break you down
yeah when you're in a position of power
there's like there's there's an
archetype of a person in a position of
power and then all the potential things
that can go wrong when a person's in a
position of power all the abuses of that
power I mean they're they're documented
right throughout history but this is one
of them control I'm telling you what to
do if you want more rights you want to
get your rights back well daddy says you
got to put your mask on even though it
doesn't make any sense
it's like we're all grounded but here's
the thing
it's it's not like things are getting
worse but their grip is getting tighter
right yeah that's what is deeply rights
are generally not given back once
they're taken exactly and that's what
the problem is and this is what the
problem when when people want to talk
about
Marxism and all the positive benefits of
socialism it'd be great if everybody
like helped all the people that weren't
doing so well and chipped on in and it
would be great but the problem with the
big state the big government is what
you're seeing now yeah regular people
making [ __ ] decisions regular people a
gavin newsom is a person yeah it's not a
genius he's not a wizard he's not from
another planet he's a human being who
grew up in the United States of America
and he has this incredible amount of
power over 40 million people a state and
he's deciding we're gonna go stage step
one and what you're gonna allow to be go
outside and look at the sunset you can
do yoga don't go near anybody you can
you can golf no cart and he's got mass
and they put this [ __ ] list of [ __ ]
that you can do and you can't do and
then they get to tap people they get to
tell people not yet not yet we're gonna
open up a little bit on May 15th okay a
little bit a little bit what could we do
you can go to the beach now but don't
sit down
yeah you can't freaking sit down you
can't tell me what to do like that yeah
it doesn't make sense this is what you
tell people please be cautious
please use social distancing let's be
smart let's take care of our vulnerable
vulnerable people and let's take care of
our health let's take care of our bodies
and to eat correct this is a good
opportunity for you to cut all the
[ __ ] out of your diet stop eating so
much sugar stop drinking so much stop
smoking cigarettes this is a good time
to work on your health
[Applause]